how's it going everyone my name is Peter
Pan welcome back to the fate of frame
part 2 I it seems to be held shot by a
powerful for this game is really scary I
made a mistake I I lost my save file so
I don't really know what I'm doing
know where I left off I think it's
somewhere here so I don't think you
missed go up yes and then no I have a
flashlight notice then but this backer I
know is [ __ ] killing me what is she
doing just staying there and there and I
am right in your face
you think of tass i think of times I
think good to have I think you're tired
because of that apparently it's got to
be something I can do I know yes
where do I take the photo ah no but I
can
okay nothing special there about her no
nothing special
I thought photo though nothing there
Oh about here no nothing they're just
how do i I don't say anything maybe here
nothing nothing
kinda creepy background noise is still
[ __ ] annoying let's back off a bit
and then take the photo maybe I don't
see something here
Oh creepy creepy creepy there's a dark
moment I got the points for that sweet
points good photo of it and she's like
oh man nice photograph I'm gonna go now
I love how someone asks are they twins
no I asked if there were twins and
someone answered no their gestation okay
we can go now could this be the power
off the camera Explorer X whatever
yeah let's get out of this place I guess
we can go back here now
she finally fellows that frickin sent
way away
Yui so annoying way only oh there's a
door here let's go
a poem no way I can't padlock than grade
of family Christmas in ginger on the
door
I don't see any ginger what but what she
always ah what is it now huh
how do you know I don't see anyone what
what do you think it has hmm
okay so that's sick photo there's no one
there
you happy now
what do you want from me what do you
want not what seriously there's no one
there what's your problem
oh there is someone there you think
you're tough huh you think you're tough
huh huh you think you're tough
whatever we want me to do then open the
door maybe could there be someone on the
other side yeah there might be a but
it's locked so it's like what do you
want for me thank you
pointing that out to me thank you
already knew that thank you very much
sister whatever you [ __ ] you are I love
her knees and oh yeah I'd forgot to pick
this up no we already read that and I'm
sorry
okay what's in here enough
uh-oh this is bad this is really this
again
I could pass good yes oh there's a
[ __ ] dead body there why didn't you
tell me
oh there's a hanging pinging yeah but
it's so faded you can't even see the
color let's take a photo
no it's not that far No
you think you're tough huh hmm punk punk
ass [ __ ]
take the photo of this be you did
nothing nothing
the signing orders the causing won't
open anymore maybe some more what do I
know
it's okay okay let's go [ __ ] creepy I
want to us more creepy the fact that
we're taking pictures of it over the
head it's there whatever let's go
come here says let's go what is this yes
herbal medicine I'm a genius that's in
here I think we're good to go
yep let's go pump Nayak's down a lot but
whatever I don't even know what we're
still doing in this place let's skip
this [ __ ] out
Oh
that's not good what what is it the now
we're screwed we're screwed
let's take a photo I see you I got you
Oh lots of pints yes what do I do with
the points I don't huh
totally feel beautiful
stop like
ah
a different place what
it looks like a cold break I know where
it is what do you want with a callable
Iser hmm you put the cold braise a photo
in your file you can view the special
photos taken in the file in the menu
alright but what do you want from me
what I love that our sisters in the
photo that's pretty creepy sick farm
yeah okay we got that we got that thank
you
yeah yeah yeah yeah we can't go there
anymore
we need to go to the cul finca leaving a
link I know where it is I know where it
is
let's go sister come on let's go let's
go
hey it's just soul sister no no no was I
seeing him on that ocean really I I
think it was in here I said I knew but
when hmm confused face I didn't mean I
meant it I I mean totally meant to do
that
sorry I don't know what happened there
you think attack huh I think it out get
out of my way get out of my way it
wasn't in here I'm sorry I'm stupid I
think it's here yeah
yes it's definitely here I remember cuz
I'm and u-turn laughs ah man she's such
a retards on that let's go come on
yes it wasn't here
no it's not it's just you and me stop it
you think you're tough huh I think you
can talk again when you're huh bossy
sister okay here it is there's like yes
yes let's take the photo of the call
boom
beautiful fun what's this the injured
man it looks like it that [ __ ] goes
to me but
the [ __ ]
Oh what all right uh what the [ __ ] no
way tiny really need a safe state in
case I [ __ ] up he said come near me
he said come near me I swear come at me
come at me
well can we go down here I don't
understand way I can't go down there
okay I think wow you think your task huh
huh I think we're gonna have to go back
stop control such horrible some nice
mm-hmm
nothing what let's go let's go I'm
always running she's not here I'm gonna
walk out in style
oh now she's running what let's go let's
go let's go let's go
mm-hmm
yiii all right let's do and now we can
go back in here what we already were in
there so it's like it's open
how is it even possible I don't
understand sorry take a photo and then
it's like open and stuff and now we can
go in here again even though we weren't
here so it's like what's the point what
it would want to be in here I don't
understand maybe you can leave this
place
Inc wants to be in the video today here
she is Wow hey I can go let's go
pinkies pumped yes look at pumps yes yes
yes yes yes
fit to fight video 5 factor finders stop
licking my keys sorry you can't be in
the video you're distracting mmm what's
the point I don't understand
tell me tell me tell me don't look
it's licking here no nothing okay let's
go yeah oh it just sort of fell down
hi I think your tower thinker tough
no no no yeah no yes just pick up ginger
key yeah I know where to go oh [ __ ] I
didn't even mean to don't hundred points
aha I'm never ready for that let's go
I'm pump ah
photo photo I need if I take a photo
[ __ ] I missed there what do I even do
with the points I don't have no a clue
let's go upstairs let's go are you
coming or what
come here ah [ __ ] sister okay let's go
huh yep
oh [ __ ] I got a phone call be right back